okay so let's go through the solution a
new site like New York Times absolutely
it's an internet service it has lots of
users and the load on the service
probably varies so the scaling of that
bending could be used a perfect match
what about a device driver testing
system well it of course depends on what
kind of system this is but just the fact
that device drivers part of the title
makes you think that it needs access to
low-level resources within a computer
remember App Engine is a generic
platform to build scalable applications
from that perspective this does not
sound like a match what about a personal
portfolio site just because it's a
personal site and probably does not need
massive scale does not mean that App
Engine cannot be of great use App Engine
simplifies development of server-side
applications greatly so this is a good
match what about a video game well if we
just mean the user interface part then
App Engine is not a good match appengine
is used to develop server-side
applications